To get t by itself we first need to add 2 to both sides. Then we just need to
divide both sides by 3. So now we have t equals 1 third times log base 2 of 3
plus 2. Well what do we do with this? We know that we want to find out what
number this is equal to. But our calculator doesn't have a button for log base
two. That means that we need to convert this log base two of three into
something that's either a natural log or a log base 10. I'm feeling in a
natural log mood. So let's do that. Know that log base two of three will be
equal to the natural log of three. Over the natural log of 2. So, let's
substitute this into this spot. OK, so now we have t equals 1 third times the
natural log of 3 over the natural log of 2, plus 2. This is calculator
appropriate, so let's pull out the calculator. I am just going to enter all of
this in. I have 1 third times the natural log of 3 divided by the natural log
of 2. Plus 2. And here's what that equals. T is about equal to 1.195. Awesome,
we went through a ton of steps to get to our answer, but we did arrive there
eventually. And along the way you got to practice a ton of different techniques
that you've learned throughout the entire course. Awesome job.